bienvenidos a este programa define de
años sobre Estados Unidos en el que
hablaremos sobre los principales
desafíos del Presidente yo Bailén en el
2022 la tensión de la administración
demócrata está puesta en mantener el
poder en el Congreso en las elecciones
de noviembre para esto tendrán que
responder acertadamente a otros retos no
menos importantes como el mejoramiento
de la economía sortear las nuevas
variantes del cúbito y solucionar la
situación migratoria entre otras sin
embargo si el Partido Republicano
recupera la mayoría legislativa como ya
muchos analistas están pronosticando la
opción será inmediata y agenda demócrata
será muy difícil de ejecutar los 2 años
restantes de gobierno bloqueo político
que aprovecharía la actualización y
limitaría las opciones de reelección de
Joe B a continuación les contaremos más
detalles sobre los principales desafíos
que afronta los demócratas en el 2022
[Música]
Enrique Arias vendedor ambulante en
Columbia Heights Barrio Latino de
Washington forma parte del casi 40% de
la población de Estados Unidos que no
está completamente vacunada este
salvadoreño desconfía de los efectos del
fármaco convencer a ciudadanos como
Enrique seguirá siendo uno de los retos
de yoga Challenge en el 2022 para
aumentar la tasa de vacunación
han bajado cuarto esperanza de un cambio
de que se haga algo
tal vez no sea tanto como los activistas
como nosotros queremos
pero pienso que hay grupos importantes
como los primers como los trabajadores
agrícolas como algunos sectores de los
trabajadores esenciales que si necesitan
ver una solución entonces yo tengo
todavía la esperanza de que va a haber
algún tipo de legalización para ciertos
sectores de la población
el margen más obvio dónde veremos mejor
y así simplemente el plan y él es en la
reducción de las tasas de pobreza la
expansión del crédito tributario por
hijos bajo el plan de rescate de América
estima una reducción de las tasas de
pobreza y menores de edad en el 2021
desde el 14 hasta el 8 % aún así es
criminal que la pobreza infantil en
Estados Unidos uno de los países más
ricos del mundo sea de un 8%
responder a estos retos y mantener el
poder en el Congreso no será una tarea
fácil para B quién tiene una aceptación
que ronda en el 45 % y su partido está
dividido entre moderados y progresistas
de hecho Xataka demócratas ven con
preocupación que los logros de
Presidente no se estén reflejando en
apoyo popular ni potenciales votos para
las próximas elecciones legislativas de
noviembre el votante estadounidense
parece responder más aún agenda
nacionalista que pone en juego el rol
hegemónico de Estados Unidos en el mundo
y sus muchas importantes como el cambio
climático y frente a los avances
políticos y tecnológicos de China un
direccionamiento de la política
estadounidense que abre camino a un
nuevo orden mundial muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado en este programa
especial en los invito a seguir con
nuestra programación